it's fair to say that if you care about
csgo
at all you know who twists is
soft doughy eyes a sunshine smile
sick tats even sicker hair and a
penchant
for propelling projectiles into faces
russell twist's van dulken has cemented
himself as one of esports's most
consistently world-class gamers like
this man isn't a man at all he's an
aimbot
let's twist have a kit yes he does and
i'm a scout oh here we go
for the job god i'm not oh what
oh that's the badger that's what you
want to see
but as it turns out he's also a bit of a
weirdo
you see in human aim aside there's one
let's say idiosyncrasy that sets twists
apart my muscular i have a very
overextended claw grip
um kind of known for having a pretty
weird grip what's
even crazier of course is how nasty he
is
in spite of it and twisting the corner
there should be no way out my god
how has he done it picking up a quick
triple so how and why did one of
counter-strike's craziest crack shots
develop such an
unusual grip what did sponsorships have
to do with it
and is there a way to know whether it's
better or worse
not only in terms of execution but
ergonomics
let's find out
[Applause]
okay so first things first make sure you
like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications so that you
never miss a future episode of cracked
since i mean that's why you're all here
to watch this
handsome boy talk about counter strike
now for those who don't know
twists is a canadian counter-strike
competitor who in addition to boasting
an
intel grand slam and nearly a million
dollars in prize winnings
has long been regarded as having
really really filthy aim
the tldr is that after entering the
competitive scene back in 2016
when he was 16 twists bounced around
such rosters as tsm
and misfits before being rightly
identified as a prodigy and subsequently
picked up
by team liquid in 2017. fast forward two
years he's winning
every tournament in sight cementing
himself as one of the best gamers his
game has ever seen
and helping to skyrocket north american
counter-strike to
unprecedented levels of success but
chances are
you know all that and if you don't you
should totally check out our story of
twists
since this dude's life story is awesome
wholesome
and genuinely very inspiring but in any
case
that's not what we're here to talk about
we're here to talk about his [ __ ]
maniacal mouse grip you see unlike the
vast majority of mouse wielders
twists doesn't clutch his clicker in a
way that conforms to any of the
so-called
standard grips instead he
well i'll let you see for yourself you
see my middle finger
is over the right mouse button and my
pointer finger is always hovering
but most fun it's not just because i'm
in the main menu or anything i actually
it's always like this
i never actually have my finger on the
mouse button ever
so what are the so called standard grips
and
why is twists such a deviation needless
to say
everyone holds their mouse differently
but the general consensus
is that over the years a handful
of go-to grips have emerged i mean it
was
right there and since you all love
colton's technical explanations
so much i thought i'd hand things off to
him
so he could expose at these different
grips for you oh wait
he can't because he's a controller
worshiping casual
keck w keep talking all that
[ __ ] dimitri it's gonna feel that much
sweeter when you finally catch this
smoke
speaking of controllers if you want to
hear me talk more about controller grip
you should check out our cracked episode
on left-handed gamers
i mean you should check it out anyway
it's a good video when it comes to mice
there's
obviously a lot that goes into your grip
the size of your mouse the size of your
hand your arm positioning and mouse
sensitivity are all gonna factor into
which mouse grip
feels most comfortable to you now while
i definitely know more about how mice
actually work
i have to admit dimitri when it comes to
actually clicking heads with them
you're probably the expert so by all
means
gush about mouse grips [ __ ] nerd
oh i will anyway pokey fun aside
the grips that we are here to talk about
are the claw
the palm the fingertip and the myriad of
variations and combinations thereof
thankfully there are tons of creators on
youtube who've already proffered
infinitely more intricate explanations
of said styles than i ever could
such as rambo and rocket jump ninja but
the gist of it
is this a palm grip is when the player
lays their hand
flat across the back of the mouse it's
generally regarded to be the oldest
most popular and most comfortable of the
three
and offers the steadiest form of hand
control the trade-off
of course is that you sacrifice a ton of
finger control
in fact there are some extremely famous
gaming mice that have done
wonders to disseminate this type of grip
the most notable of which
being the zowie ec1 not to mention the
innumerable sea
of successors and spin-offs forged in
its image
next you've got your fingertip grip
where the mouse is held and maneuvered
solely using the tips of a player's
fingers meaning that the palm
floats above the back of the mouse and
never actually makes contact with it
contrary to palm fingertip offers
exceptional micro control but can make
it difficult to execute
big sweeping swings lastly there's the
claw grip
which is kind of a hybrid between palm
and fingertip
here the player anchors the back most
part of their palm to the back most part
of the mouse
and grips the front and or mid sections
with the tips of their fingers
now the differences between these
various styles may seem pretty minor
but let me assure you they're not
mouse grips matter don't believe me just
ask
garrick forman a phd candidate at brock
university
who specializes in neuromechanics and
ergonomics
if your body is used to
using a palm grip there's going to be a
certain
synergy and sequence of muscle firing
while you're using it and if you're
switching to something that is
significantly different like that so all
when you lift your fingers up to go into
a claw all of your extensors
are shortening your flexors are
lengthening everything is changing
pretty much
so what is it that makes twist script so
unique
well as he himself put it he's developed
a
very over extended claw grip whereby his
palm rests on the hump of the mouse
not the rear this means that his fingers
hang over the front
giving the appearance that he's claw
gripping a mouse that's
way too big for him why because he is
we know this because of how twist's
chaotic clamping technique came to be
a story behind this weird grip style and
let's just say
it wasn't by choice it was because of a
sponsorship
and the reason my mouse grip is like
this is because in 2017
when i joined team liquid i was forced
to switch from
smaller mice to a bigger mouse because
uh team liquid had a racer sponsorship
at the time
and i had to i'd switch to that battery
and it's a pretty big mouse and flying
it isn't always viable
so to compensate or i guess
uh adapt i over extended my fingers so i
can still claw
the mouse and feel like i'm in control
of it now it goes without saying that
twist's grip works for him
the dude won a grand slam made hltv's
top 10
and was at one point statistically the
most proficient head clicker in the
whole of competitive counter strike
there's no denying it this kid is
well cracked i think that the most
gifted player that i've ever played with
mechanically is twists
without a doubt i think that he is more
mechanically gifted than me
uh i think that he really shines and a
lot of those uh very hard like aim duels
and stuff like that
holds them in front of bathrooms and
apex comes out to finish the job can't
do it
it's easily as he hoped twist even gets
one at range down to just two how does
twist fly this second saiwu
he peeked out ak available he's gonna
grab it on the run and he's got the bomb
he's got armor this is a straight one on
two but alex is close twice
about somehow a third he's using the
deagle he's got confidence in his name
and he sees it
[Applause]
and the twist shows us all the maple
syrup is just another form of liquid
what's even crazier is that apparently
it works for
others as well my boy achieved for
instance one of the top gunners on tsm's
siege roster has become sort of reputed
for running a grip
that is staggeringly similar to twists
insofar as it's pretty much carpal
tunnel incarnate
um they're like yo does anyone else use
like a grip like that and i'm always
like i mean twist
has a similar grip and it's funny
because like i never like copied his
grip or anything you know
it was just like i don't know one day i
just started like i guess going up my
mouse and eventually like my grip just
became where it was
achieved came from xbox so i wonder if
it's like a
uh i don't know like a calling from you
know his old his old days of like maybe
like this claw grip on the on the
controller or whatever i
i have no idea but it is definitely a
curse to say the least he is like he is
up in there his
his fingernails are like rubbing against
the mouse pad essentially
but hey this guy is nasty
like twists achieved frags the [ __ ] out
not only has he earned himself back to
back third and fourth place finishes at
the sixth invitational
but if it weren't for bolo being an
inhuman aim hacking divinity
achieved could easily be the most
consistent player on tsm
i want to be careful though because he's
not exactly in fighting shape but
he's allowed to swing out the support
from his teammates gone and what's this
achieved allowed to run out he's got a
nitro cell as well oh my god achieved
of course there are downsides to this
type of grip
and they're pretty much exactly what
you'd expect them to be
i will say the one thing about his grip
that kind of sucks that i've noticed is
that he has to re-center his like
hands along with this mouse a lot you
can pick up the whole mouse but it's
it's harder you know what i mean so it's
harder to
like reposition your mouse whenever
you're like doing 360s or
or stuff like that so i do kind of think
that it's harder to reposition the mouse
in certain instances
but i i do think it does make it quite
more precise but i once again i also
haven't used another grip like a
just a regular claw or fingertip or palm
but
if you ask achieved he'll tell you he
loves his grip
and like twists thinks that there are
genuinely positives to it
see i don't know i kill i feel i do kind
of feel indifferent
because i really do like my grip and i
think
personally i think my grip it makes it
easier to be more precise but i feel
like this grip
offers quite precise like best movements
uh you could put like a lot of pressure
down onto the mouse pad
and you just feel like really in control
of it the question of course is at
what cost esports athletes don't
care about their longevity for the most
part when they're in the moment
and they're at the peak of their game
you know when you're the best the best
you're not going to change anything that
might
take you off the the podium you know so
people are i
people are gonna be very reluctant to
kind of change for longevity's sake but
you see people
you know ending their careers at 25
because they get injured they can't play
anymore
now that's not to say that either of
these dudes careers is going to be over
at 25.
it's simply a reminder that the
importance of ergonomics
cannot be overstated make no mistake
esports athletes are just as capable of
sacrificing their bodies in the name of
competition
as well actual athletes and it's just
as much on the orgs organizers and
developers to ensure
that that doesn't happen as it is on the
players themselves
i think that's something if esports
wants to continue to rise
and they want actually care about player
safety they want to improve it they need
to
find some way to either utilize sponsors
to create adjustable peripherals or they
need to allow players to use what they
want
and to be clear that is not a pot shot
against liquid
they are a world class org who has since
built a state-of-the-art gaming facility
in europe that fulfills their players
and creators every need when it comes to
diet
exercise and equipment nowadays liquid
permits their players to play
how they want with whatever they want
that said
it's important to remember where esports
started the incredible strides it's made
thus far
and how far it still needs to go if it
has any hope of catching up with
traditional sports
because remember achieved mouse grip was
adopted entirely by choice
twists not so much which begs the
question
would twists have become an even nuttier
rifler if he hadn't been forced to use
such an ill-fitting peripheral
or does part of his genius his
secret sauce as it were lie in the
strangeness of his grip
who can say maybe maybe in a different
situation with
with a different mouse maybe he wouldn't
have gone to where he is i mean
who can really say but as far as
you know his his arm and wrist health
goes
i think that he will end up being a
better spot if he has a mouse that fits
his hand but
who knows what we do know is that it
speaks to his resilience as a player
that twists was not only able to
overcome that mechanical barrier
but achieved such remarkable success in
spite of it
so while i'm certainly not encouraging
anyone to throw ergonomics to the wind
and contort their hand like a freaking
pretzel at the end of the day the common
wisdom continues to be true
it doesn't matter if you're twists
achieved bolo
or a silver tube the best mouse grip is
the one that feels most
natural to you my whole method to the
mouse group is just like
whatever feels good i mean i just put my
hand on the mouse whatever feels
comfortable i rock with it if it's
working it's working if it's not
it's not change it up um but yeah as
long as you feel comfortable as long as
you're not actually hurting your wrist
or your
your hand that's all that matters unlike
virtually every other aspect of your
config
mouse grip has real-life consequences it
won't just affect how
sick you are in the server but uh
outside of it as well no amount of clout
is worth carpal tunnel
i think your grip should be
one that you feel you perform best with
and is most comfortable and
and everyone is different everyone's
physiology and anatomy is different
i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all best grip just like in
in most workplaces or tasks there's not
a one-size-fits-all method of doing one
thing and a high degree of variability
exists in pretty much every industry
is it true that mouse grips like twists
and achieved
could be improved from an ergonomic
standpoint
sure but those dude's top priority isn't
comfort
it's performance they're out here trying
to win majors
you're not don't compare yourselves to
them do what feels right to you
because at the end of the day your body
knows what feels right
and what doesn't the road to mastery may
be
long and arduous but it shouldn't be
painful it's like that baby bait quote
man
then was that quoted oh it was so good
he was just like
when he came to valerian and people were
like oh it's so skillful it's so hard
and he's just like sorry so you mean i
had to headshot a roadhog
three times as widowmaker behind two
shields
in the face but i i click a dude's chest
with the op and he's dead like
oh sorry i'm like
yeah i didn't realize your game was that
was the
yeah the elite e-gamer game sorry yeah